in
2021 we actually sent out over 115
million notifications to people at risk
in India and Bangladesh alerting them on
floods coming their way eight hours or
more before the floods actually get
there so this is really life-saving
now if I look back and I think about
what what are the ingredients that we
can actually take away from this kind of
experience one is that if a problem
seems to be too difficult it doesn't
mean that we're not going to be able to
solve it
it doesn't mean that we need to throw 20
people to work on that right away we can
actually do that in a staged way and
move fast welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to episode 1000 of 20 minute
leaders this is a very special episode
for a multitude of reasons first of all
it's a big milestone the Thousand
episodes and I'm still wrapping my head
around what that even means and what
I've learned over these thousand
conversations with some of the most
amazing people that are around and
really distilling what leadership is
about and I'm extremely happy and proud
that for my 1000th episode I have one of
the most amazing leaders I've ever met
my own dad yossi Matthias and in this
longer than usual episode we'll dive
into a little bit who he is and the
journey that he's been on in
establishing his own leadership style
and his own curiosity and the impact
that he makes for the world and it's a
huge huge impact and so I'm very very
happy to welcome my dad Jose Matias who
is vice president engineering research
at Google advancing AI to help transform
Healthcare conversational Ai and the
climate crisis he is the global lead of
Google's Health AI Google's crisis
response and climate crises AI
initiatives and pioneered conversational
AI Technologies previously he was on
Google searches leadership for over a
decade and established the Google center
in Israel and grew it to over 2 500. the
oversaw Google site in Bangalore India
through its four-fold growth and
oversees Google's expanding Research
Center in Africa he is a founding lead
of Google's AI for social good and of
Google for startup accelerator EOC is on
the computer science faculty of Tel Aviv
University with over 100 published
papers and the inventor of over 60
patents he was previously a research
scientist at Bell Labs a visiting
professor at Stanford and of course an
entrepreneur and we'll talk about that
in the episode among his recognitions
yossi is a recipient of the gettle prize
and the ACM can malaki's theory and
practice award for seminal work on
large-scale data analytics
[Music]
to 20 minute leaders episode
1000 thank you for being here Michael
Matias thanks for having me here thank
you great honor from now on I'm gonna
call you Dad on the show so that I can
reduce my own the the the the feeling of
calling you you'll see
um and I'm really excited for this
episode I've done I guess 999 other
episodes and and this is by far the most
exciting one for many reasons
um
definitely one that I I thought I would
be most prepared for
um but it turns out that coming in here
I almost feel like I am furthest away
because I know there's so much for me to
to unpack here and and I'm really
excited it's gonna be a really
interesting Journey for the two of us
having this conversation which um you
know I'm excited for everybody also to
to hear and and get to know you through
some of our conversations so thank you
for for agreeing to do this right it's a
great pleasure and it's an honor and
it's pretty amazing that it's a it's
been now
999 episodes wow pretty pretty wild wow
it's pretty it's pretty wild
there's a lot of things that that we
could talk about you know the world is
changing you know first software was
eating the world and now data is ruling
the world
the world as we know it through our
priorities is Shifting you know and and
entrepreneurs and scientists like
yourself are shifting mindset says to
what we should be prioritizing on
and and we'll talk about that as well
but what I really want to talk about is
your journey in the context of the
incredible things you've done and the
way that you're doing them today and the
journey that you're allowing other
people as well to go through and we'll
we'll get to that but but we have to
start somewhere and I want to take you
all the way back to your childhood we're
going to start there
because
um you're a very special thinker and I
can testify for that myself and I want
hopefully to learn myself and for others
to hear a little bit about what brought
on this special thinking and you I want
to start with
and your your runs you're an athlete
growing up
what what is that part of your life
well that was actually
I was actually a late athlete because I
only started in high school so I had a
very short career to be honest I mean
that was pretty good in you know running
jumping and all that stuff but it's only
in uh middle of high school that I
actually went and made it a very serious
Endeavor for two years which ended up
when I was drafted so for two years I
was a serious athlete
but that athlete wasn't just in the
track and in the competition
I recall
um that running was also a pretty
significant part of your own
problem-solving mindset and especially
in mathematics
yeah so one thing I discovered when I
used to I used to run every morning I
think it was about 10K this was kind of
in my very short period of being an
athlete uh this was my morning routine
now at the same time actually the thing
that I liked most was
um probably the one of the very few
things I actually liked at school at the
time
was a month and I had I was privileged
to have an amazing math teacher his name
is Ori
um he's a very special teacher for many
in Israel a legendary one
and he used to bring some Martha Lincoln
questions to class and throat us but
also try to solving himself and
occasionally he used to
you know call me
in the afternoon when he was walking his
dog about hey
um they used to go to the balcony and he
used to
throw some ideas and we used to kind of
exchange ideas
so what I discovered is actually the
time that I got the best ideas to tackle
those
uh pretty tough problems typically that
they give in these math olympiads was
when I used to run
and once in a while I used to kind of
suddenly something hit me and I used to
perhaps stop for a moment and if needed
to draw something in the in the sand or
in the mud
just and in many cases I think I found
out that actually when running
that's actually where the mind was
actually a little more relaxed to
think more freely not in a kind of in
Wonder a little bit and that's where
some time actually some of the best
ideas came came about
and uh years later I actually discovered
that the same also for when I had a long
drives
or just just a long period of time
people call it sometime now Focus time
yeah it's it's time that actually
somehow you reflect and you're not
necessarily making the effort to solve a
problem but then suddenly it hits you
hey this actually comes together
so actually this was a nice kind of
combination of course this was only when
doing these long runs when doing
um kind of more intensive exercises in
the field that's that's not where great
ideas come actually to mind
was was mathematics always
you know a core piece of your interests
you know or do that start before high
school
well it was always something I'd like to
do but there were times that actually I
was more into writing and drawing so in
fact if you'd ask me in elementary
school what I'm going to be probably I
would say a writer
uh and um I was probably blessed to
growing up at times there were no
screams so and I loved reading so and I
read a lot I sometimes I read two books
a day
so what what kind of book did you like
all sorts of books you know romance and
you know literature classic literature
stories about uh you know fiction a lot
of uh just through a lot of stuff and
then later on I actually started also
reading non-fiction and
and later on I started actually getting
more interested in philosophy books so
this was at some point philosophy was my
main interest in fact well I remember
you telling me you were you read some
philosophy books at nine and so when you
say later on well I was thinking
philosophy I started reading it a little
later but I was a little I was concerned
with them with questions that are more
like um you know existence what people
now call the metrics and all that stuff
um simulations and all that these kind
of matters they were bothering me for a
little while until they were not so
um until I figure out actually I
shouldn't be bothered with them because
um we have a lot enough to worry about
in our kind of in whatever we call
existence so and a lot of exciting stuff
happening around us anyway
you drafted to just like you know
everybody in Israel and um
and then I may recall that this period
of time was was also very monumental
you meet uh my mom obviously and then
and it's already that's a a very special
the most special moment probably in a in
in the service
um but it's the most important point in
my life so yeah so it's it's a very
important one yeah some parents say that
either their kids are born is the most
important day of their life but okay
um but
that was also a time but that's a
precondition okay
um music is a huge part of your life as
well
very active part of your life and I
recall that also really took a leap
during your service which was flying
planes so it's not the most trivial
service
yeah so music is an important part of my
life interestingly enough as a kid I did
not appreciate it as much
so I have to thank my my father uh who
kind of insisted that they take those
piano lessons
um I'll bite my resistance
and um and it was only again late in
high school that I started appreciating
and uh discovering the beauty of
classical music jazz
and actually starting practicing
seriously only when I was actually
during my service so at some point I
actually bought this used piano brought
it to my room which was pretty unusual
yeah and for a few months I actually
used any available hour to actually
practice so I did a lot of progress in
those few months
before I became too busy to do that
and ever since I'm kind of still
practicing once in a while so it's
making time trying to make some progress
ever since
and and why jazz
it's a good question
um I mean I love classical music as well
but chess is what I discovered about
jazz is that it has this combination of
depth
complexity
however it has this both discipline as
well as freedom
so improvisation is something that has
in fact is rooted in very deep
very deep structure very deep kind of uh
uh you know relationships within the
music and rooted in a lot of legacy of
ideas and techniques and uh and a lot of
knowledge
and at the same time
it's totally up to you to actually
follow your
whatever yours you'd like to do
and it has this other aspect of playing
together and that togetherness has this
beautiful aspect of
communicating
working as a team if you will I mean
people like to draw this analogy and
rightfully so between play music and
teamwork and organizations and all that
stuff and I think there are many indeed
uh one can just think about everything
that happens at at work and teamwork and
from music but but that's not the reason
why I actually liked it in the first
place it's just because of its beauty
and the ability to actually
um it has this something that touches
both the mind and the Heart
in the figurative way
and um and it's something that actually
as you learn to appreciate the structure
the more your the more you know about it
the more you can actually appreciate it
which which I think is is pretty magical
what was the leap that you that that you
made into the you know the research
world because as I recall even when you
I mean throughout the years obviously it
became a very prominent researcher but
initially when even we're starting at
kadinia
you weren't necessarily even going that
route right
so yeah it's an interesting question
first uh probably the first thing I
actually enrolled to the university is
philosophy I did it when I was still
serving in the Israeli Air Force so I
took a few classes and um I I didn't I
didn't like the way it was taught so I
actually decided that it's I'm not going
to prefer just to read it on my own
um I had a out of high school and again
a lot of it thanks to amazing teachers I
had
um I appreciate mostly math and physics
and initially I plan to study math and
physics
it was only thanks to my brother-in-law
who
suggested hey why don't you check
computer science that I decided to also
add computer science on top of that so I
had a pretty heavy schedule for the
first year
anyway
dad tell me a little bit about that
interaction
um you know that's that's tip of you
because that during that time was it it
definitely wasn't as popular as today
but what was sort of the sentiment
around computer science when you were
studying it or when you were starting it
out
well it was relatively early you know
this was around the time the typical
computer science was part of the mass
School in most universities so it was
still the kind of the first generation
of computer computer science
um but the basics were already there
right so first it's kind of the basic
stuff different languages at the time it
was Pascal that was the modern language
which is of course by now long for
burden in terms of teaching
um but that's not the material the the
main the main thing is that when
when encountering these questions of uh
of algorithms and problem solving
and the Magical capability of taking a
problem and finding the right approach
and the opportunity to create because I
think that computer science is one of
the is an amazingly creative discipline
because all the time you well in a way
mathematics it's it's similar to
mathematics in this sense but it opens
up all these new dimensions
so one can think about computer science
is something that has
connections to mathematics to
engineering
um and many similarities also to other
disciplines that we have now of course
it touches
any anything in life that you can
imagine
but what got me I guess is the this
notion that there are these I love I
love solving problems
so this was this was one thing I did
used to do as a kid which was taking
this newspaper problem riddles and
liking to tackle them and try to solve
them
uh as much as I was kind of hooked on
these math Olympiad kind of questions
so this was actually an opportunity to
solve problems in a way that actually
solves something real
and I think this combination of
hey you can actually take this
intellectual challenge have the
satisfaction of having a solution for
that
and the solution is actually something
that does something useful
is something which I think is is pretty
profound I think and actually this is
something I enjoy up to today this is
kind of the combination of
uh creating something which is
non-trivial it requires some thinking
and some creativity some perhaps
sometimes solving something that some
some that other people could never do
but once you do that you actually have
something that is useful is solving a
real problem and uh and this is pretty
powerful
so and once I discovered that actually I
I was very passionate about physics so
but I decided to nevertheless
move my focus to computer science
interestingly enough what I started in
physics even
and even on the first senior that I did
was actually quite influential later on
in my research but that's a separate
story
what what is research in your eyes
you've you've written um many papers and
some of them have become to to be pretty
foundational Concepts I had the the
honor of um of being your plus one for
the ACM Awards this last year in in San
Francisco a pretty wild experience still
in University myself and going and you
know in University I would be lucky if I
had the opportunity to for for a minute
with one of my professors in the
computer science space and I walk with
you into the the ACM Hall and I see the
entire faculty just lined up waiting
pretty much pretty much to talk to you
among the some of the other winners or
recipients and even that award I believe
was up for something that you've done
many years ago right yes this was kind
of um it was called the kind of like his
theory and practice award actually for
work that a theoretical work that over
time proved to be to have a significant
impact in practice
and so that so you know I'm sure that a
lot of people you know can can you know
fathom and understand you know this
creation of taking something and
leveraging problem solving and
creativity to create something tangible
but when you do research I'm I I I'm
really curious as to what that
experience is like for example when you
were a researcher in Bell labs and
you're sitting and you're and you're not
really sure what's going to happen what
is that research process looks like from
your from your mindset and how did you
experience that
foreign
okay there are various types of research
of course there are some research where
somebody is trying to research a very
well actually the the connecting for
research activity I guess uh is always
at the end of the day is to select the
problem that you try to solve
and then looking for
new ways for for solution essentially
namely Now by definition it's about
solving something that is not already
being solved otherwise it wouldn't be
research
now the depth and the type of research
varies there are some time some problems
that are open
um you know for many years with many
people trying to solve them and uh and
and these are kind of uh and and some
quite often the the way which research
is done in the research Community is
that um there are some some aspirational
big research problems I mean in computer
science the famous one is for example P
versus NP but yes
um but then in order to get there
researchers the research Community
people are defining steps towards that
so they're trying to advance the state
of the art of what we know about many
things
or in computational Pro in algorithms
sometimes it can be let's solve an
important problem such as a matrix
multiplication and let's find a better
algorithm to doing though and just
recently for example there was um a few
works of showing how to do metrics
multiplication even better than known
before which was kind of got a lot of
attention rightfully so but anyway it is
an example for a problem that if you
apply the usual text the the basic
algorithm it would take you know certain
complexity but then there are some
better approaches to do that so now of
course when you think about the about
research then the the breadth of it is
is so broad because essentially every
every car every startup
every project every place you need
there's a room for research because you
you encounter all these problems that
you say hey wait a minute for some of
them I can actually use node Solutions
but there's an opportunity here to do
something better
let's see if we can actually find a way
to do that even better
now again as I mentioned some of the
research is really kind of relatively
simple or applied research which is
let's apply whatever we already know and
let's try to push the solution to a
better one sometimes it's really to go
very deep in trying to solve something
that is even surprising that nobody
actually even believed they could do
that and and there are quite a few uh
fortunately there are quite a few
examples where things that are believed
to be very difficult eventually are
solvable and sometimes even the solution
is is simpler than people anticipated
which and that actually creates all
these amazing progress that we see in
technology
can you can you paint me the picture of
what you as a researcher was like what
that experience was like for you
personally perhaps at at Bell Labs or or
at the Weitzman Institute or or any of
the locations where you or or Google
where you continue doing pretty intense
research
sure so so one thing about the research
one important aspect of course is the US
to ask the right questions is to select
what do you want to work on and then
what is the question that you want to
ask in fact when you think about
research at the University academic
setting uh an important role of the
academic advisor the professor
is to help with asking the question and
guide the sequence of questions
and asking the right question is so
fundamental and so important
because you want to ask questions that
are both both matter there will going to
give you progress that eventually will
get you somewhere
but also that are solvable in a way that
you can actually hope to get something
out there you don't want to be too easy
because then the promise is going to be
not as meaningful on the other hand if
they're too hard then perhaps it's going
to be a frustrating experience and not
useful to anybody involved so that's a
tricky part is how to make the right
selection and how to do that now for a
personal point of view
um when I did it actually it varies over
the years so one thing that uh my
interests are actually
pretty Broad and uh and all my style of
study is always is was always in
research was always in a way kind of a
combination of there was always
something that I was extremely
interested in focusing in that
particular moment and then there were a
few others that were kind of just kind
of
um to to have additional kind of to go
after some interest now one of the
important aspects was always to keep
some discipline so that not spreading
too thin so this
this trade-off between focus and
diversity which is another trade-off
that we only to worry about whatever we
do also when we're leading teams and we
develop products when we build companies
uh was always there actually also for me
so now when I did my master for example
at the Whiteman Institute with other
Shamir Professor shmir it's um uh I I
actually looked into a problem that was
touched on many disciplines so it in a
way this was an amazing opportunity to
touch on fractal physics and digital
signal processing
and the cryptography and security and to
do all that for a problem that was
motivated by actually just encryption of
analog video signals
so I loved actually bringing all this
together and I actually was an
opportunity also to go back to uh you
know my physics routes as well as to
learn a lot of things that actually were
very helpful later in my my kind of
future research
for my PhD I actually decided to totally
switch to a different direction I
decided to actually want to do something
theoretical computer science
but I wanted to look into a problem that
I thought is going to be important which
is to do parallel algorithms how to do
how to run how to design algorithms for
a future case of
um you know where we are going to have
many many computers that we can run in
parallel
and my thesis was essentially about how
to uh it was titled highly parallel
randomized algorithmics and essentially
showing that you can have many
fundamental problems where if you have
many many processes say you have a
problem of size
million and you have a million
processors you can practically solve
many of these problems in constant time
under certain assumptions and of course
it requires required many kind of new
and interesting uh algorithmic
techniques I remember still that
somebody came to me and said these all
these are very uh you know elegant
algorithms but why would you need to
solve anything in constant time and when
on Earth will you ever have so many
processes so uh anyways so this was a
nice uh so this was my my kind of PhD
listening to this now
to come but after my PhD actually my
research tastes again shifted and at
some point I was no longer interested to
solve theoretical problems per se
I was actually looking to see how can I
actually find a way to apply what I
learned on Parallel algorithms and find
ways to actually apply it to real power
computers
which and that's actually where I
started looking for some places where we
have to use parallel computers in the
field
now interestingly enough this led me
into working with um identifying that
the uh the largest particle computer
commercial that the Apollo computer at
the time that was in use in the world
was actually not too far from where I
wasn't a researcher develops at the time
and this was a computer data warehouse
by uh teradata which was actually part
of ATT the parent company of bellabs at
the time so actually reached out to that
group and I found out that yeah I could
actually apply some of my
understanding of parallel computation to
actually solve real problems for that
they actually struggled with for many
months and give them solutions that
would actually work in practice so this
was actually this nice example where
having the understanding the algorithmic
understanding of what's going on was
very helpful to solve a problem that
engineering alone was not was
insufficient
now
one of the magical things about research
and I guess technology development
is the serendipity
of how to you uncover new opportunities
so actually by solving the problem for
parallel computation that's where I
actually learned that they have even a
bigger problem than that which was how
to handle with the fact that the amount
of data that's accumulated every day in
the data warehouse
was so big that their basic computation
could not handle that
actually that's where I was exposed to
what people are now called the big data
problem early on
and helping them solve that problem
actually led me also to also do
theoretical research that eventually is
the one that led to that ACM award that
you were mentioning earlier so we have
all these circles that are connected in
ways that sometimes are difficult to
predict yeah but but one one you know
see I want to thread a needle and you
want to
you do see the Curiosity in a very you
know broad field starting from from
philosophy and Mathematics and problem
solving and reading fiction and
non-fiction uh to music and classical
and jazz and and obviously uh flying
planes in Military and then and
transitioning to Academia and their
theoretical applicative theoretical
applicative and and then you meet
entrepreneurship as a CEO of a company
during the you know the the the right on
the change of the Millennia
so going from now research to being a
CEO being an entrepreneur
who's that for
yeah so entrepreneurship was also
another kind of angle and dimension that
that was quite
um
it was interesting so actually when I
even my masters after after developing
some technology I then looked to see
okay so this was actually pretty novel
and um and actually very useful in fact
uh we showed that we could encrypt
analog video signal
in a way that actually even improves the
quality of that which is totally
counter-intuitive
so I actually made a tour and looked to
uh you know visited a few places that
were looking into various TV standards
to see whether this is something that
could be useful and
um but going to the more basic so as
much as I was interested in research one
thing that I was always looking for is
to how to solve real problems so one
thing for example that um even before
starting my master
I was actually on the fence whether I'm
going to do my Masters versus taking a
job at the company at a high tech
company to be an algorithm designer so I
could actually contribute to product
development
and and eventually decided that actually
uh I I should actually continue my to my
master
similarly I had the same deliberation
after between between before starting my
PhD actually I was genuinely
deliberating whether I'm going to
actually go join a startup at the time
um or go to my PhD and it was a real
kind of deliberation so this and then
similarly when I was in bellabs it was
actually this combination on the one
hand looking into the fundamental
research and I was blessed to be in
bellabs in the mathematical Research
Center the same place that Heming was
there and you know there um at the time
the center head was uh my Gary and one
of the department has was David Johnson
also and every computer science student
should know the famous book of the Gary
and Johnson on NP completeness uh you
know I mentioned earlier NP so I really
was blessed to be
in a place that had on the one hand the
longer term research in bellabs and and
by the way Peter Shore uh was two doors
from my office when he designed his
um Quantum factoring so she remember the
first seminar where he was presenting
at the same time the desire to go and um
and and and solve a real problem for the
biggest Data Warehouse in the world
and also while in bellabs
um at some point I was exposed internet
kind of started becoming a thing
and uh at some point I I was kind of
heard a prompt you know I looked into
technology for privacy presenting for
the internet
so that was again another side project
that led actually into forming Adventure
within
um Lucent than available
at that time so this was another example
of actually taking
um
um you know dancing between research and
Entrepreneurship
now fast forward
at some point we start seeing these
convergence we start seeing that you
know entrepreneurship and research are
becoming closer together and in fact
today that's in a way I do both but but
going back to
um to the zapper chapter this was indeed
um at that time I was already a faculty
member at Tel Aviv University
and um
and this was a company that we looked
into
what can you do better for search
and um we set up and we had this
observation that by using by the way
just with what year is this
well this was 2000 uh well the year 2029
1999 yes yeah so yeah so we looked into
well can we do something
um we had some ideas about how to use
the context of
uh what people are doing as uh as a way
to improve search
and uh and develop this technology that
was
in a way also uh pioneered a few things
one is the use of context for search
and another one is actually to use
um
some techniques that are pretty popular
now of course of uh of embedding
and in order to actually use the
contextual information so as to get a
better scoring if you will of what we're
looking for and thereby improve the
search results on top of whatever search
engine which was there
and what was that entrepreneurial
Journey like for you and
it was an amazing learning experience
because
um it was
on a very uh so
I started the journey interested mostly
from the technology point of view
and I was encouraged to actually take uh
take kind of the lead as a CEO so I
found myself learning now today of
course
I mean you're teaching kids how to do
that as teenagers
um at the time I actually had the
learning from zero to building a team of
hundred people in no time in a global
way
and actually launch a product in about a
year
and do that in a very fast pace so yeah
100 people in a year
it was about 100 people with the product
that was pretty
elaborated and launching it and uh it
was a pretty interesting Year yes a year
and a half perhaps
unbelievable how do you go from zero you
know people talk about no zero literally
people talk about zero to one and then
one to one hundred and you just went
from zero to one hundred and they say it
in different context but that's what you
did how so I'm even putting aside the
technicalities of how to even
build the team and a product in a year
how do you as a as an entrepreneur
manager CEO leader father already at the
time I was already four years old I
guess at that point you already have
three kids uh in a relocated you know
and traveling from what I what I
remember and hearing quite intensively
how do you do that
uh with the law of adrenaline
and what does that mean and a lot of
fashion uh I think this was an exciting
Journey because
we knew exactly what we want to build
we had an amazing War fortunate to take
uh you know to to hire some of them most
brilliant engineers and scientists
uh on on something that was extremely
um exciting
and uh and and you know going on a very
aggressive
kind of uh milestones and doing this
extremely hard effort now
I was actually traveling since I did the
team in New York I was actually
traveling every second week so yeah uh
This was um and Coach only so this was
this was actually interesting so what
was that schedule like because we were
in Tel Aviv at that point right
so how did that work
well it was every second week more or
less to take the Sunday Night Flight
start a week Monday morning after a run
in Central Park
showing up in the office at seven
o'clock or six o'clock in the morning
um working more or less Around the Clock
until Thursday evening and lending back
in Tel Aviv Friday so this was a
this was the schedule for a few months
for 38 months pretty
um incredible I want to fast forward
a little bit
um I'm gonna fast forward a lot because
there's a lot in between
um and the and you're
you're leading
um massive teams hundreds of people
now thousands uh within Google and
um and so I'm really curious to hear a
little bit about your you know your
leadership philosophy and a little bit
about what you perceive to be your role
in the Journey of others as they grow
and as they research and as they create
I've had the pleasure of
meeting
um
quite a few people that worked with you
just a few months ago I was sitting in a
bus
um in Dubai next to somebody who worked
with you in zapper and I know a lot of
people that worked with you
17 years ago at Google and they still
work with me today and so
I know that there's a lot there and I
want to capture a little bit of your
thinking process around
what this role means to you and not as a
as a researcher because you still write
papers and do research but but as a
leader in their Journey yeah so you know
there's this um fact or cliche which is
all about the people and and it's really
all about the people and the team and
the culture
and one thing you learn as you kind of
start
growing up professionally is that
uh no matter how smart you are how
creative you are
how much energy you have and how much uh
you know effective you are
you're good to do much more when you
work with teams and when you can
actually have others actually work with
you
and um
and then one thing you adopt is actually
to uh to make
is now of course I I'm blessed to to
work obviously it will with some of the
brightest people and um and also people
that are fun to work with
no the basic thing is to to enable to
let people to try and get the best that
he can from our teams
and the way to do that is to support
them as needed and as needed is really
something that changes all the time
sometimes and um it's too is to be
involved in the right way now I like to
be involved in the details so I need to
be disciplined sometimes not to get into
the details where I don't need to both
in consideration of my own time but also
in consideration of uh to to have the
teams work in the right way
so
um so how to support people's you know
both on the selection of projects on the
right Cadence of reviews
on the personal development of people on
providing the right guidance
um you know taking my experience my
observations sometimes uh giving the
right kind of
support and making sure that we can
actually I mean when you get
one of the things that I'm extremely
proud of is to see the development of
many people you mentioned that you know
some of them started as Junior engineers
and are now
see directors VPS
um or or entrepreneurs on their own
rights and to see their developments
over the years
and their development is also some of it
is also not only to help them develop as
in better engineers and better
scientists
but some of it is actually to help them
develop as managers and as leaders
and they have to go through the same
process as well so so in a way when when
doing that that's actually where you get
all this big impact
now it's about how to encourage people
in their development but similarly in
their day-to-day projects how to you
know at the end of the day
I once gave a talk about leadership as a
balancing act
and all the time you need to do this
Balancing Act between all these
considerations in every choice that you
do
about Focus versus diversity I mentioned
earlier focus and diversity about
being providing being more directive
versus uh you know
just showing the way and uh and and let
people find the way themselves
uh versus taking decisions quickly
versus letting them evolve in the right
pace
so there's no right answer here just
right question and there's right
judgment call to do it in the right way
and different times call for different
types of actions and different
circumstances
for example what you're doing in a young
startup like you have yourself is
totally different when you do when you
are in more mature stage is different
when you do have bigger teams
so
that's of course a part of of what we do
here you mentioned being an enabler as a
as a key part of
your role and Journeys
but I I'm not sure my perspective that's
enough you know you let you know you it
sounds to me have a very significant
role in people's Journeys in the way
that they make decisions and the
confidence that they may perceive in in
a large organization right this is not
they're not just you know making they're
they're working in a in a world of
possibilities that you are creating for
them and I I recall quite a few
instances in which
in the way that you've that that you
represented entrepreneurial thinking has
actually led to some pretty Monumental
um projects that even made some pretty
significant impact on on people's lives
yeah so the notion of entrepreneur you
touched earlier in the question of
Entrepreneurship and uh and I'm tied
also to Innovation okay and uh you know
entrepreneurial to being entrepreneurial
is something that I think is unrelated
to where you are where if you're in a
small company in big company
um it's really the notion of and of
course you wrote a book about
entrepreneurial right uh for for
teenagers so
uh
yeah so so again one of the choices that
you need to do all the time is to make a
Call of how to select the right problems
and whether and to take some the right
level of Judgment of whether or not we
want to invest in them
and and also to have the right level of
confidence of whether we want to do
something but also do the right
adjustments
so I think it's um
you cannot over analyze it
but you cannot take that as a whole pass
to not do the right level of diligence
so
um let me give an example
one of the one of the projects I'm
really proud of is our efforts around
flat forecasting
where we're actually
um so just a little background uh one of
my roles I'm leading crisis response
efforts within Google
which essentially means that it's uh
people are coming to Google to look for
information during crisis natural
disasters and more so we develop
Technologies and products and making it
part of search and maps that people
could find help actionable helpful
information about what's going on during
those crisis
and a few years back I found out that
actually one of the most significant
natural disaster namely floods uh we
just don't have the right information to
present to people because floods which
are assumed to expect it to estimate it
to to uh to have thousands of casualties
per year
the really helpful information would be
for people to know before it actually
hit them
so a few years back
um it was on my list there's a problem
that we need to take a look at but it
seemed to be a very difficult problem
and not clear whether we can actually do
anything about it
so actually asked an engineer to start
looking into that part-time
to see if we can do anything about it uh
as namely how can can we use machine
learning in Cloud technology for doing
that
and a few months later seller who you
know and uh he came and showed Oh we
showed enough progress on the problem so
I asked him what do you need in order to
run a pilot
and said well
um I need to engineer it's okay within a
few months we had the first pilot fast
forward we now have Cloud forecasting as
something that is already launched in
um India Bangladesh and 18 more
countries wow it covers hundreds of
millions of people globally
uh the team Advanced the state of the
art of the science for hydrology uh
publishing a dozen papers including two
of the most downloaded papers in the
leading Journal of hydrology and we have
a platform working in collaboration with
Academia and governments Etc and we
actually have a system
and last year in
2021 we actually sent out over 115
million notifications to people at risk
in India and Bangladesh alerting them on
floods coming their way
eight hours or more before the floods
actually get there so this is really
life-saving now if I look back and I
think about what what are the
ingredients that we can actually take
away from this kind of experience one is
that if a problem seems to be too
difficult it doesn't mean that we're not
going to be able to solve it
it doesn't mean that we need to throw 20
people to work on that right away we can
actually do that in a staged way and
move fast
um a second one is that uh you know if
it if it's good to have a high enough
impact it's worth trying I mean that
that's actually the reason for that yeah
and uh and and of course there's the
power of actually working in
collaboration with many so this is kind
of an example for uh if you will sort of
taking taking this kind of
entrepreneurial approach for something
that looked
um difficult
um and of course I can go on and on and
on many other such examples anything
well let's say let's dive into what you
really
um spend a lot of time on today you're
spending a lot of time on on health
you're spending a lot of time on climate
you're spending a lot of time on the
intersection of artificial intelligence
communication
and and climate crisis response and and
health
let's I'm let's talk a little bit about
how
today's technology and not just
technology but you know sort of where
we're at in terms of how technology and
specifically AI is positioned to augment
or change a lot of the ways in which we
we live and perceive our life
yeah so first artificial intelligence or
AI is uh transformative and
we are actually in the beginning
um
not not so much just the beginning
because we made some progress of or for
revolution it's transformative obviously
so yeah it's obviously going to
transform and impact every aspect of
life
and we we see that actually the
interestingly enough you know you asked
me earlier about the early days my my
kind of um final project in my first
degree was a machine learning program
that plays a game Othello
and um and even then using some
techniques that actually go back to
someone's work from the 50s which was a
state of the art still when I was doing
my studies so it wasn't wasn't much
progress in just a few days and nights I
could actually write a program that
actually could beat me probably wouldn't
be the the the best player of of that
game
and we've seen that milestone in 98
where computers actually built for the
first time uh you know the world chess
player uh Kasparov
uh but the real Revolution actually
started out a decade ago of course with
deep learning and what we've seen then
is nothing short of
um astonishing
so
machine learning or AI which essentially
is is kind of encapsulating machine
learning and other machine learning is
the biggest of course the most
significant technique within that
it went from a situation that we aspired
to try and solve a problem which are
matching how we as humans are doing to
areas where it's actually doing a better
job than do we do
and and it from a technology point of
view
um which essentially is means that we
can harness this technology to solve
real problems at scale
which is pretty profound so I give the
example of flat forecasting and then
again this seems to be a two difficult
problem though so many parameters how on
Earth
um visually
can we predict where if water is going
to go well it turns out that actually if
you take enough historical data enough
machine simulations uh and use that in
combination with hydrologic physical
models you can actually come up with
models that are predictors of actually
it's going to behave and use that in a
way that is useful
uh similarly we see that can
transformation in every other aspect now
the nature of technology is that there's
this old saying that
um it progress is slower in the short
term than you anticipate but it's faster
than you in the long term than you do
than you anticipate this was a kind of
paraphrasing on this kind of um the idea
is that you think it's actually you know
self-driving cars another example we're
saying well it's going to take longer
than we expect every year
yeah I mean just 10 years ago everybody
said
yeah everybody said this is not going to
happen it's a science fiction and now
it's only a question of when how many
where where is actually going to go to
similarly conversations you know we had
this project duplex which was
started out as let's see if we can
actually
try to get things done over the phone in
real life so that we don't need to do
all the errands on our own
and again starting it it was kind of a
moonshot
but then not only did it actually
get to the stage that you could actually
use it to make restaurant reservations
and
find opening hours but during covet
uh we could actually use that in order
to make phone calls to millions of
businesses to ask their opening hours
and and whether or not they have masks
and curbside and whatnot
and put the business information on the
web and have billions of views that
actually got the right information just
because we could use AI to do the kind
of scale that there's no way we could do
actually with with people doing these
calls you know I remember I was in a
California and during that time when
when Kobe just said I remember one day I
was gonna go pick up some food and then
or make a reservation to to pick up some
food and uh all of a sudden I see a
curbside pickup all over Google Maps
locations and I remember thinking to
myself wow these people are you know I
can't believe that all these business
owners went to Google Maps and updated
their all of their operations this is
crazy everybody has this information how
did that happen so quickly and only I
guess a year and a half later I heard
you say that this was actually a bit you
know duplex played a big part in it and
that was that was a a pretty you know
pretty Monumental thing to think about
when you really think about the
situation in which millions of
businesses are changing
pretty much overnight and you have
hundreds of millions of people that are
relying on these businesses for their
day-to-day and you know we're digitized
and all that but but if this human
computer interaction
this was a really meaningful part it's
it's pretty astonishing so this is an
example where you use AI in order to
help with human interaction and and by
the way when talking about how to use it
for the phone there are all these other
use cases for example using duplex
technology so that if you need if you
encounter this um if you need to wait
for an agent you can let the phone wait
for you and have duplex do the the
communication with the agent but until
so you pick up the phone but there are
other approaches in which for example
the fact that we can actually use AI in
order to help you with the communication
so that to help you take on calls that
you are you're not sure who's calling
and you don't want to talk to a
telemarketing something called call
screen which is actually an idea of of
mom as you know so one of the most
people popular features of the phone
uh but and and in addition of course to
the fact that you can actually now use
AI to make conversations multi-model so
today we can actually deaf people can
actually have real phone conversations
because they can actually read on the
phone what is being said and again this
is an example for a project that came
from uh innovation of one engineer came
to talk to me
saying hey I have an idea of how to help
people using some of these technologies
that we already
developed with additional Innovation and
this is a work of sapir that did amazing
job on this uh what we called
um live captions for calls and I
remember you you mentioned a few years
back uh you know one of your standards
and and I don't believe you have too
many as a good reader but you but you do
have one which is that if anybody ever
comes to you with a demo that they want
to show you your your doors open and
that's what and and you're stopping to
see that demo and sort of as a way to
encourage actually doing and not just
thinking of ideas but actually going and
implementing and implementing them and I
know quite quite a few of the projects
that became very very meaningful came
out of that yeah to the team is that if
you have a demo to show me I'm going to
step out of any meeting if I can
to see that uh but uh but yeah I I
really I I think that Innovation can
come in various shapes and forms and uh
and and and that's a great idea but
going back to your question about these
areas so conversational experience is
obviously one big area that is we see
now of course huge transformation uh
especially with large language models
which probably deserves its own kind of
um uh episode and I know you're looking
into that quite a bit yourself
um but let me touch back on just earlier
about these uh two areas that I'm really
spending a lot of time on one is about
health and one is about the climate
crisis and both are I think
um have direct impact on on people's
life
and obviously and in the future of the
world and in both we can actually have
ai
um play an important role to actually
have help address many of the problems
and um if I think about let me start
actually with the climate crisis
um and and you know what I mentioned
floods earlier and floods is uh one one
thing we've seen in the last couple of
years has actually increase in the
frequency and intensity of floods
because this is actually the result of
the climate climate change
uh similarly we see more wildfires so
and we we are using AI in order to have
real-time identification of wildfires so
that we can actually help with this uh
other
um you know result and there are many
other areas of uh how to use AI in order
to help address the uh the what what is
now called adaptation for climate change
uh there are also many opportunities for
climate change mitigation which is how
to use AI in order to
try to reduce the amount of carbon
emission
and again I think there are many
opportunities here we are having a few
efforts one that we spoke about recently
is about how we're using AI to help
um minimize to help reduce the amount of
carbon emitted in cities by having a
better more optimized traffic light
scheduling turns out that this can
actually reduce quite a bit the amount
of carbon emitted and we can actually do
that quite effectively so again another
example for Innovation because the idea
for doing is that
um people came from one of our Engineers
uh over dinner conversation
as a side note it's not a random
Innovation that comes out of a random
conversation it's in the context of
having the team members all spending
days if not weeks on coming up with many
many ideas
and looking into them and looking for
the ones that are going to have the
bigger impact so Innovation and how to
actually drive for that is is a whole
process that we can discuss also at some
point
um so anyway the notion of AI for
climate crisis obviously is a big topic
and it's one of the areas that captures
a lot of my attention these days because
obviously it's important for Humanity
it's important for all of us
the other field which I'm really
passionate about is uh is health
because again health is one area that we
know that AI
is going to he is going to make
tremendous change
for and I know in many aspects of Health
anything from how doctors are using
information and accessing information to
helping out fill gaps with doctors where
doctors are not enough Specialists out
there to helping us you know we have our
watches we have our phones there are
sensors they can actually help us
identify many things early on
I'll give one example from a recent
visit I was in uh in in in Thailand just
recently
and I was visiting uh some clinics that
are implementing
uh one of the technologies that were
actually developed by my team which is a
technology that helps screen for a
condition called diabetic retinopathy
which is a con this is a condition that
is um can lead into blindness and people
with diabetes actually are at risk to to
get this condition
if not treated they can be become blind
if treated it's uh it's it's actually
relatively easily treatable the problem
is of course identifying it easily early
enough the good news is that it's easy
to identify by experts on an image the
bad news is there's a shortage of 100
over 100 000 Specialists are actually
doing that
and in a seminal paper that was
published it was discovered was
identified one of the top papers of the
decade by Jama which is a leading uh
medical journal uh our team actually
showed that you can actually do the
identification with the AI of this
condition quite effectively
and what we what I was visiting in
Thailand is actually a clinic that
implemented this AI system where I've
seen people coming
and two minutes after actually sitting
in front of the camera device they are
getting the Diagnostics but by the AI
which tells them whether or not they
need to go and get a treatment
it was a better result than they had
before
before they had to wait for weeks if not
months
and is an example of how AI can actually
help in this case cell from blindness
well just about the same time we
announced about uh you know partnership
with a few players in the US about using
some AI that can help with mammography
screening and that's going to save lives
I anticipate now we're just in the
beginning of employing AI for health I
think we've seen great momentum a lot of
that is happening in many places
um so I think this is one of the
examples where we're using going to use
technology to enter into so many aspects
of the healthcare
um you know Journey helping consumers
helping doctors helping the Public
Health Systems uh the opportunities are
are pretty amazing here
that's a incredible literally yeah I see
no spending
um your time as a researcher
entrepreneur leader
um
and um and World traveler pretty much at
this point going to all these places and
making a positive impact you know and
and
having a really Monumental uh effector
and so I can't think of many things more
more impactful than that and I know
firsthand how how proud you are of of
these accomplishments and how everybody
around who's observing them is is so
um you know mind blown about you know
how the the ways in which you use these
Technologies to literally change
people's lives in some cases save their
lives and in some cases just augment
them into really meaningful ways from
the way that you allow them to to use
their to continue using their senses
like eyesight
to being able to communicate or being
able to have better human phone computer
interaction right and say that whole
range that you touch on which is pretty
amazing and you know I started this show
three years ago really with the goal of
learning and with the goal of getting to
know you know stories that will inspire
me to to be my best itself and my most
fulfilled self in terms of what problems
I want to solve and tackle and the type
of leader that I want to be and so first
I want to thank you for serving as a as
a key inspiration along with with Mom
and and all like Leon and and everybody
else around me and and I I want to end
with with one question which is not a
trivial one but it's a but it's an
interesting one nevertheless and so if
you had to conceive a Vib and distill
for repeat for a single piece of advice
that that you would give me at this
point uh from you know looking back in
this last hour of our conversation and
your journey you know what would be a
key piece of advice to give in me right
now
well let me start saying that uh first
that
um talking about inspiration first time
inspired by so many people around me let
me start with the
and with uh Leon or yourself
uh my kids that I I'm really proud of
your accomplishments and uh and every
person going after their passion and
doing
uh such an amazing journey in that
uh also by my team so you know we didn't
discuss much about the site in Israel
that I was fortunate to start
uh some 16 years ago and um I'm pretty
amazed of
the development and and the
accomplishments of of everybody there
and what they were doing there I just
want to acknowledge that we had an hour
of dense material and still we somehow
glossed over you starting Google site in
Israel which today is more than 2 000
Engineers but we'll leave that for
another episode
totally uh and I won't first refer back
to to this occasion which and again
thanks for inviting me for this
thousandth episode I remember you when
you told me about starting this kind of
stuff actually before I remember when
you were telling me about your habit
to meet an interesting person every day
and um and learn from them and leverage
the fact that you were in the Stanford
campus with so many interesting people
around you
and how you pivot it
in college they're actually doing it in
over video conference and then took this
extra step to convert it into 20 minutes
later
which was an amazing wonderful example
of actually taking a crisis and making
um
getting the best out of it
and um and and kudos for that and I know
how popular your your kind of program is
so having a thousand people
kind of um telling the stories so that
so many people can actually listen to
them and learn from them I think is is
quite inspiring on its own so uh really
congratulations on this accomplishment
and I love the Curiosity you're
following and uh the fact that this is
actually the driver for doing this kind
of program as many so many other things
they're doing
what advice can I give
um
as I mentioned earlier you know I guess
we have many similarities one of which
is that we have all these vast interests
and we try to do everything at the same
time
so
don't stop doing more than one thing at
a time because that's what gets you
energized
but at any given time we do need to make
our selections of where to focus more
and where to less when to put things on
pause and when to actually double up
it's essentially a very subtle priority
exercise especially for those who are
interested in more than one thing
so it's a judgment call of how to and
when to focus and how to do it properly
that's true I guess for every it's
almost the same advice I would give
every to every team leader
you know or every startup so you know
there are startups in the early days the
the cliche says you cannot be too
focused
well take it seriously
um at some point you say we want to
invest in the future and you do you want
to take some of the risks it's a it's
all the time making those judgment and
adopting them
to the situation to the circumstances
same with life there are certain times
that you are working around the clock
it's not sustainable for forever
um so there are times that that's what
we do we do all these all-nighters but
we know this is not the the right pace
for long term sometimes it's necessary
and then of course we want to find the
right Cadence
um
I think having fun along the journey is
always important it doesn't mean having
fun every day I mean part of work is
also to deal with less fun things in
order to do the to get the things that
we'd like to do
so uh but uh there's this notion of
following your passion
which I think is true in the right
framing it's not only every day and it's
about taking into consideration
everything around us
and um and life is not linear so
everything that we do is a learning
experience for something else if it asks
me you know many years ago
what I'm if I'm going to be doing what
I'll do today I wouldn't anticipate it I
wouldn't necessarily expect that if many
years ago I had to choose between doing
research versus doing product
development that will be time actually
that made day-to-day job is actually to
do both deep research on some of the
most
uh important problems and at the same
time this leads to actual product
development that actually touches
people's life
so you know these are things that I
could not anticipate
so life is full of surprises not all of
them are great many of them are amazing
Dad yoshimatias thank you so much
Michael my son thank you thank you
[Music]